about
my what's that qu thinking about my no
my
stop thinking about my stop the prank is
that this large massive guy we just
heard 6' 5 in starts weirdly and
ominously harassing a random door Dash
driver he just trying to pick up some
food and deliver it to a customer this
guy comes up and he's got his phone out
and he's like putting it's it's it's
repeating this weird phrase and he's
putting it in colie's face and he keeps
pursuing him getting very very close to
him you know and colie's backing away
and he says stop three times he's trying
to leave it's not like he he's trying to
leave the situation he's being pursued
and after the third warning he takes out
the gun and he shoots him